we control the physical world
and it is not so easy to
control that we also see what
problems Tesla has from time to time
or the others and mechanical engineering
that is actually a complicated
matter and we are
probably still leaders there but
we do both  the Chinese as well as
the Americans are slowly but surely
competing and I think the
crucial question for the future is
whether the hardware of the
physical world will be able to integrate the software
and thus arrive at a better
solution, or will the
software people dominate the hardware world
say the tesla idea
who who who who actually wins
this game physicist
mckinsey partner state secretaries
ministry of defense head of the
digital wheel of the federal government so
Katrin definitely seen a lot of
perspectives already worked in the
economy worked in the
public sector and we
talked about  of course her
view on topics like AI like cyber like
werf is actually Germany where is
the industry going so the really big
other topics in conversation with someone
who really needs to know who
is really deeply involved in the day’s questions that
’s Katrin Suda let’s go heartily
welcome hi thank you very charming of
you
still unusual unfortunately iron
résumé unfortunately probably yes
you can judge better you talk
to many more people so you are
somehow a physicist
crass technical college somehow
attended in Aachen and I somehow
heard somewhere you attended  but
I think that says because when you
were in Aachen to choose the university because the
weather was nice, it was like that, my
father was also a physicist and he
said you absolutely have to
go to a technical university but there were also
technical universities and
Germany  it was at that time
and I think 7 so I
looked at the different cities and of
course Berlin was too big for me Munich was too
far away for me Darmstadt was too
small for me and then I landed and
the weather decided the cathedral was great
the old town  wonderful yes okay
physicist and then you somehow founded a theater group in
this very male-dominated summer at
Technik Hochschule
and also studied theater studies. I did
that later
when I did my doctorate in Bochum
but yes I
played theater at school and was passionate
and came into  Aachen and looked around me, there
was no theater group and
I thought I couldn’t be, and then
I founded
the theater group the
poetic seizure with a friend at the Technical
University okay,
of course, there’s a large, how do
I put it, overhang of men, so to
For example, I studied with 300 people
who were about seven women
and that's why it was of course
difficult to recruit women for the
roles, which means we also had
a few men and boys who then
played women's rooms and of course
not always quite easily at
that point somehow  because you're
incredibly impressed by the development,
I think and that's a reminder that you're committed to
diversity, are you on behalf of customers, yes,
I wrote my thesis in
social studies at school about customer regulations,
and where should a
good start then, say, somehow,
university  level or later only
with any before, in
any case, if we
look at the management of the
universities too, then we can
very well talk about quotas, we
actually have in every branch of industry in every
industry whether that is science, whether
that is mechanical engineering, whether  it does
n't really matter, it's the same
phenomenon everywhere that the further up we
look, the lower the proportion of women we
have, although we now take business administration
50% of the students are women, but
why weren't there at some point in
top management
in the physics course, or
seven women been in one of  200
people during the quota somehow
makes sense, yes I think that's very, very
difficult, because then
of course you can't
force people to enlist, but I think we
urgently need to think about how
we can get more women with more potential
in the Human Studies subjects in total,
i.e. mathematics and engineering sciences
I really think it's an important way
and that shows there are
a number of examples that it
works now, that you're advertising the course in a
completely different way, that you no longer
say it's natural science
and physics, but here, for
example, world sciences, here
you can contribute  researching climatic phenomena
and also contributing solutions
you can by making maschinenbaum
you don't just have to think about building a car, you
can think, for example,
how can I somehow
develop modern carbon capture technologies, which means that the degree program is
no longer loaded with, let's say, hardcore
natural science  but much
more with the problems that our
society currently has and
because of that you also attract completely different
people and, among other things, many
more women is a lever, but we
know that there are a lot of levers,
we actually have to start the
discussion again  lead about Mona education
that's a long
discussion is actually long
overdue because studies were in the
80s 90s have shown that the
girls who come from a pure mathematics
physics class only for girls
study much more then
very late in their careers now when you
Management or introducing that is
actually always super difficult
because then you find these people in
the often not in the whole amount
you need them from my point of view you
have to
start thinking about these quotas very early on, so now in a
positive sense that you say okay
somehow have to go to math class or
or even earlier then the same or
physicist is definitely
definitely actually we have to start in the
daycare center so that’s where the
so-called handicraft deficit starts, so to
speak in the daycare centers because of course
we don’t have enough either  invest in the
training of the child educators,
mostly the women are
there, either unconsciously or
consciously, both are transported,
so it’s quite classic, they
dress up, then the girls are the
princesses, then the boys play with
the building blocks and erm, or build them
Radio apart and the girls
just do something different and I think I need
to give more impetus, especially the
scientific, the technical,
the curiosity, the fun in disassembling
things, that it
works the same across both sexes, uh, and we know something
Scandinavian  countries but also from
many investigations and to be
honest they are relatively old that
starts there we have to invest
where the talent starts to grow with you
it was the case that your father was also a
physicist and then you
set up a workshop in the basement and so on  that
means you're in your parents' house, so to speak,
then
you can say that you've slipped in a bit, yes you can
say that, and then after
the doctorate they go straight to me,
yes, that was a bit of a coincidence, I
can't put it any other way
Hardly anyone knows that anymore, probably
hardly anyone who listens, but back when
I did my doctorate in 2000, there was still
something like overqualification and there were
academics, the unemployed could
n’t find any jobs,
I applied to Siemens, my favorite employer
that's the German company so
you're absolutely no longer invited me to the
job interview and uhm yes you
wrote me back the overqualified
dr title next to it
we don't need a bachelor's degree overqualified and
that was at the time for me I did
n't understand it at all and then of course
I did  I programmed a lot in the
promotions, so of course I would have had to go to
one of the big programming companies
I didn’t want any of that and
then remind me wait a minute and then
why did I
go to the job interview? It
gave me great pleasure, they
made an offer and  I've tried
it out, you have to say yes, so you're
not only generally
inclined to good grades in terms of your school subjects, well, let's
say moderately, well, I don't think
the Studienstift or things are given to me for
free  So,
unsurprisingly, you
went through everything at McKinsey and would have to be promoted quite quickly
and become a partner
in a few years and then because that
somehow became too boring or,
as I said, no, I
loved the work very much, so you are allowed to do
complicated things there  Solving problems and doing that
in a very nice environment with
great people, so in that respect I really
enjoyed the work no, there is
a standard way that
many consultants also take part that
at some point they switch to the client's side, so to speak,
and  That was
also the case for me, the only unusual thing
was that my customer was the
public sector, so to speak. I
ended up managing the public
sector in Germany, that is,
the advice that mainly
happened with the ministries, and that's how I
then did it  I also got to
know Ursula at some point on my own, I published my
study on the subject of a shortage of skilled workers with her and
yes, and then she
asked me at some point and then
I said yes, so then she was
Minister of Defense and you then became
State Secretary in Distribution,
it’s just the ministry  there has
meanwhile gained a completely new
relevance there, you wouldn't have expected it at the time
or I don't know,
of course it's always such a
discussion what did you know what didn't I
am when I
started in the Ministry of Defense in
2014 Crimea was one so that tends to happen
we also to neglect so
that was already there Russia
yes and at that time people
died there and that was also it was
an armed conflict that I don’t think nobody
called it that openly but nevertheless
it took place 20 14 and  At the time we
also said yes, national and alliance
defense is, so to speak, in addition to the
foreign deployment pillar and must
be strengthened again, so there were
already efforts back then, but it wasn’t
as terrible and large and
far-reaching as we are now, but the
question is how big and far-reaching  does it have to
be how does it really look like in the Bundeswehr of
the Ministry so now in
the last few months when you
could hear the news about the war you don't want to
and thought
for God's sake everything is
already very encrusted  and we
also somehow the things do
n't work and everything there for far too long and
then a few helmets are
sent instead of somehow so tell me
a few of yours in sight well to be
fair I got out in 20 18
that was a long time ago and I can  I do
n't judge at all what has
happened since then or what hasn't
happened, so I actually want to distance myself from that
and
I can definitely say one thing, that
what I play inside is often
different than what you read in the newspaper,
so I was  on the other
hand and I understood quite well and
armament Bundeswehr that is such a
complicated field we actually have to
start with what is actually
the right social debate
and I would question whether the
right debate is whether it is the Leo
A1 or  A6 or what do I know what is
but what is actually the role of the
Bundeswehr how would we actually
think about defense and this
social discussion with that
everything starts and then we can
get down to the complicated, really complicated mills of armaments a little later  and
I would often wish that we would really devote ourselves to this
dialogue or this topic
in its complexity, but
we are probably still a
step away from that. Are you in favor of
conscription?
I would look at it this way, the
discussion of conscription is also
first of all  a very very
complicated one because you have to express yourself if
you want to get so deeply involved in
someone's life I personally think it's
difficult I think
we can definitely talk about whether we
generally want people to be
more socially committed and on a
broad scale  I think that's a
debate that you can have, so how
much should you give something back to the state
and how do you rate others, but
then there is the question of parental leave
and so on and so on or
caring for relatives I can only
say from one  From an operational point of view,
I believe, as I said, I'm five years out,
it's very, very difficult, if not
impossible at the moment, and
probably doesn't make sense at all
to overcome the Bundeswehr with nothing but new recruits because they simply
take a long time or whether the
structures are right for that at all  not
laid out so we would then need
barracks we would need even more
material even more protective vests even
more ammunition even more opportunities
to train people but and I'm
not really there I was
n't on the military side of
things but on the civilian side, so to speak
think whether that
makes military sense with the type of missions
or not that others
have to evaluate afterwards
disappointed about how it ended a bit there was
a
committee of inquiry that
dealt with it because then a lot of
your kinzig colleagues were commissioned  and
that was then questioned,
I think, and it didn't look so good from the outside at first, except for that, oh
you, that
's a big field, so I'm
happy about the
investigative committee, no, I wish
that someone
had an investigation on their cheek, no, but
I did  I really appreciated the time
I
saw and experienced an incredible amount and I do
n't want to miss that and what I remember so
much when you read up a bit is that you
really got through with so cyber for the first time  Warfare have started
to work and
think about it somehow,
hopefully building up structures then, yes,
that's correct, in fact,
Ursula opened a new military domain on her own during the time erm cyber
that you don't do every day
the last domain was the air  The
Air Force was opened 100 years earlier,
so that's a
big thing to say, we
not only have not only water, not only
land, not only air, so to speak, but we
also have virtual space,
I found that incredibly right, we
have that very strong then  with structures,
we have set up our own command,
i.e. a military structure,
but we have everything around it, we have
set up research, we have set up an innovation app, we
have also invested a great deal
in technology, so to speak, we have
developed a new IT strategy, we have
developed a cyber strategy
Incidentally, we were involved in training and
recruiting because of course
the so-called cyber soldiers also
have to have skills other than
maybe running through the woods,
but computer skills, so to speak,
how do we get this talent in the first place, how do
we get it, how do
we keep it in the Bundeswehr
and have invested a lot there
and I also found it very successful, so
the Bundeswehr, in contrast
to other state institutions
here, has not yet been hacked, which
means it can defend itself very well
and I say that with some
pride what we do  all or the
colleagues have achieved is that
Germany from the five ICE, i.e.
the USA and their four most important
allies at the table, had a place at the table
on their topics, you do
n’t have that every day, so I thought it was
important there too  quite a bit was successful and
I thought it was so necessary because
you get that here in the
podcast again and again with cyber and not
just cyber crime, but also cyber as
a political weapon a
political instrument whether it's
espionage or completely different things
we have it, we see each other now in the
war in Russia it is an increasingly
important domain and it is huge it has
now become an industry
that is becoming more and more
professional, so to speak, terrible as it
is and in that respect I found it very
important that the Bundeswehr is  is there
enough together in Germany,
so I can primarily only
speak for those for the Bundeswehr and
I think that we are well positioned there, it
can always be done better, of course
we then of course have the
Interior Ministry’s responsibilities for
internal cybersecurity, there were often responsibilities there
and there were still, but
I didn't follow that too intensively, again and
again, questions of responsibility and how
the cooperation models look,
I can't even say how things are
going at the moment, but we
always argue a lot about responsibilities,
also between the federal and state governments that I
believe  I'm not always helpful and
then of course the companies come
into play no because
basically companies have to
protect themselves and I think that the
big ones should all
have that on their slip of paper by now whether they always
do it sufficiently I can't
judge either  I'm much more worried about
the smaller companies, also the
small infrastructure providers, so for
critical infrastructure we take
some smaller municipal water
suppliers and we had a white
hacker who showed us how
easy it was to use a controller, i.e.
a control element, not
the classic one  classic
server but via such a controller in
a public swimming pool in the
baby pool and zack
said with one thing I could now
set the temperature in the baby pool to 100 degrees that's no longer
funny that's and then you realize how
quickly you can  Things, and now
we can say wake up the baby,
but how quickly can he, for
example, turn off the lights somewhere
and I think we really need to
ensure that our critical
infrastructure is adequately protected,
which is
not always the case, even with a small IT department
having to have sufficient staff
in general meanwhile delve deeper into the whole
issue of security you’re also a
member of the supervisory board at Crowd Strike that’s why
I have a different approach but it’s also
about something
traditional, so to speak the internet was
basically not intended for our completely new
internet world nope
means it's actually not
reliable enough, it's not fast
enough and it's not secure
enough and Cloud is creating a
decentralized
server network that now has 250
decentralized locations and is replicating the
Internet in this way, but making
it more decentralized and
faster because I  I'm much closer to the content, I
can cache it there, I can
do it much faster and secondly,
I can also install
security firewalls and so on much more clearly there,
which means it's made more secure,
it's made more reliable, so you
have to
buy a service that you as a company have to buy
and then you come up with
different servers where you can
store your entire web application website, so to speak, whatever you have on it, that means
even if one of them is down, the
other can start it immediately and
it's just faster because you
accessing the driver you then somehow have
the server closed and it's all the same
and every server has every
service, that means it's not that
then you have to go back to the
pond, it's actually every
server has every service that does it  the
model is also very unique
and because you yourself have invested a lot in
security, you can of
course map these security products
and then they also offer
private customers there is also a
private customer with a free
offering and as a result they simply see an
incredible amount of it  Internet traffic
that means the streching vectors the
attack vectors see the
examples that we now have completely new
magnitudes of DDoS attacks
and how do you come to the
that is the American company
that happened at the time to the current
CFO Thomas
Seifert is also German and we
met once and that's how we got in touch
and yes, then I
went through a process of dismissal, as is
usual, there are several
candidates and then at
some point they decided on
a company that did the same  is appreciated by many digital
experts is also
regularly in our podcast Klöckner
is there I believe, among other things, a fan
of it also my colleagues here with no
active difficult to
forget in advance of the preparation
but still market cap don’t you know
15 19
years so already when  if it were a German
company it would probably even be in the
DAX I would say yes I don't know
anymore 40 in the DAX yes but in fact big
and of course you can see the
classic copywriter
200 so completely different so not 200 but
200 dollars or euros share price  well
then the marketing would not have been like that it was
almost tenfold
but well many of the
shares have now joined in no we can have
a look at some of them but still
the starting price was 19 now as i
said at somehow 40 or
even 60 for a short time
I stopped
looking at stocks every day a long time ago but it's
a very impressive company because
the core model is a deepack and
it's just incredibly innovative
how they replicate and very visionary
founders and they just put a lot of value
on privacy and we have now  also
have also built a geo location so
a product where the data is
no longer in the USA there is a
huge debate about the data and
really try to do things differently
than we do from the traditional
American what can you even
say  So if you now
say that you have a European perspective, so to speak,
we take data protection differently seriously and
we actually think that our good
information and, in particular,
personal data should be protected,
I have the feeling that
a lot of elites in
Germany are also
reading the newspaper during the discussion  or writing a newspaper
is important, but the majority
at that time, 80 or more million Germans,
I have the feeling that most of them do
n’t care anyway and everyone
just clicks away all this data and
in the end if you’re asked then
of course there’s a social one too  expected
answers yes of course it is important but
the truth is it is only really important to very few
people yes well one thing
is of course what appeals to you this
concentrated news is of course
amazing no one can understand it you
can read it and I think that has happened
too  established a model that does
n't make any sense, no, everyone gets it,
everyone gets it and I think
it would actually have made more sense to
create other conditions so
that what you're doing makes sense,
you can't control it
but  is also wrong in my opinion
because when I get on the elevator I do
n't want to click on it three times
that I can somehow take the elevator
that I know he couldn't
crash it I want the TÜV to check it and
then I'll look there TÜV checked and I  I
think we have to think
very differently about digital models
because, as I said, I get into
the elevator, I don’t want to click in, I
don’t understand any strange concentrations,
I want there to be independent
certificates, tests, etc., and
what role does it play, I think it
’s different  one thing is,
of course, personal data and
I do believe that we don't want all the things
we google or
maybe find out again soon no
idea what's going on in the
search machine market Well um that we
that all this comes out
None of us want that, so that's
personal data too, so nobody
just wants the search history to be out there
and I don't think anyone wants
the messages that you really
write that are out there, so
nobody wants that traffic to be open,
I think there would be  most
people say no I don't want that after all
where I live maybe
something else if we used to make phone calls
what was in it and the other
is then of course also company data
so where then of course the big
question of data usage we all believe
that that's data  So it's not the new oil,
that's a wrong picture, but the
new breeding ground from which new
business models and new insights
are created and that data is simply
copied and used that's what we want,
I don't think it has
anything to do with gdpa, but still
that  that there is security and that I
want to determine whether I give my data
out or not I think if
you discuss things like this with a double-click
I think a lot of people
say that would be
general is
still amazing to me at cybers today that
So when I do that, whenever
companies are attacked then it is
usually due to the fact that some
user
clicked exactly, somehow when
some fake e-mail address
replied and then
downloaded some obscure document and you
think okay enlightened person
might have stumbled onto it  that it's
a funny address that you do
n't always download it or something you do
n't even know um it's going to be so trivial
and so simple and in the end it's
the weapons that
are used, you think okay with the weapons,
that's how  always somehow from the
Middle Ages so it's that simple yes
fishing is one of the main problems that is
of course becoming more and more
differentiated always sophisticate would have
ne now there's voicemail fishing that
means you then also have
really good fakes so you
get the feeling yes  really the boss so
that means that they are
constantly developing the next generation
of attack sectors but yes it is
just as someone who speaks to me
on a WhatsApp
like my boss or and then I think to
myself ok force must now yes then you
will get a call  and then so on and then
actually that's the
next that or that's the next
generation there are now also
text messages with something written on them no
that's the next generation
that means e-mail is almost
out again because and  that's of course a red
race, so who has the better solution?
I was at a
wonderful conference last year about the human firewall
because I think it's about it right now
because people are an important attack vector,
the individual and
then you can see wonderful experiments
so if the title of the e-mail
is e.g. a new salary bonge
then click on the trailer of the Excel
table or the boss
urgently needs you bonge does it of course
so she is also a lot of psychology
and that's exactly where we had to start to
To train people and as
I said at the same time the next wave
is then already the SMS where we actually
thought
if you could turn up the baby pool
the camera fishing in the
municipal works purely no that just
went through a controller that means
that many so many many the the
operational technology that is in the heaters, in
the ventilation systems, there are
also controllers everywhere that
raise the temperatures or they just
pump people and they
are increasingly connected to the Internet and the
problem is this operational technology in
contrast to the server and the computer  you
have learned that in the IT department
yes you have to make the servers we
have to make our computers our PCs the
mobile phones safe that has been
learned and that happens more with it that's
fine but that happens but you have a
completely different world, so to speak, the
world of technology  the increasing Internet of
things everything is linked together
everything is hacked and that's what it's all
about. A lot of
attackers are coming in somewhere there's a
famous example like
that a few years ago a
server got a hacker into a
server room  hung in, namely over the
fan of the server and then managed
to get in over it and then it
has such a clock frequency, so because
he then changed the
clock frequency of the fan
and then physically
influenced a hard drive, so
everything that you can think of happens  can't
imagine at all
these are other attack vectors
this has nothing to do with fishing sorry
anyway the first access so via the
people or via the technology and via
the technology increasingly more just via the
controlling via the hardware technology
and not so much anymore  about IT okay
back to your life for a moment the
ministry of defense was
over then at some point you’re still with Frau
von derleine exchange so off and then
we’ll definitely talk but then you
know what it’s like when you
don’t have that much to do professionally  then
you just don’t have that much
vacation anymore then things went on like this for you
at least if you
researched a bit now or I
always followed it from afar then
the big discussions were already expecting
you would soon be going to VW
too  not now as somehow somehow
I don’t know a beginner
logically but then there was a
direct somehow VW board position was
then it
board members which is a super
central topic for VW so in general the
group is yes it is the big field with which
you have to keep up right now and
like that
[music]
but you would have done it or yes it was
probably a mixture of no idea
naivety hubris madness I
don't know but volkswagen is of course a
fascinating group and uh there
is also a part of the state holding involved when the important
pacesetter in the  Automotive industry and
if Volkswagen is the question,
Tesla is now winning, you have to say,
or will the Chinese win the
electric and generally the mobility market,
or will Volkswagen succeed because
the whole supplier industry and
everything depends on it and um the question is you
think I forgot  but i
think that is 15 20% of the
national economy, this makes
up this entire sector, which means it is probably
one of the most appealing tasks
people have, both from an innovation perspective and from rethinking mobility in general, as well as from the whole economic and of course technology perspective  in that respect I was
actually tempted and yes I
would have done it the supervisory board of
Volkswagen did that was that to the gentleman that's
okay that's a bit
the area where now this is checked so
it's not directly underneath but of
course I have  I also led the discussion
about how I could
possibly also play a role with one
of the cameras, because of course they had exactly
this question of what role,
how do I get the car
protected, which is also a huge topic,
and cyber comes in by the way  Then again,
interestingly enough, cloud
flair again because they have a decentralized network
and you will of course not be protected at all via the latencies
if you do it centrally,
which means you will
have to think about decentralized security solutions. Cloud might then or might
also come
into play  and in any case
yes was the center of the discussion you must be a
shareholder of VW
no idea because I'm out
less
we're going because then so I do
n't know what this twitter is so
I can't say anything really
not active
for reading no really  not no, because there
are already many very
intelligent people in the world who
share their things,
yes, I'll take a look
again, okay, how did it go, of course, so you
somehow have the VW topic already
in the room, nothing happened  what's
done next well well basically
it was isn't that easy what are
you going to do after
the Ministry of Defense well where I've
seen a lot I've been dealing with a lot of
questions especially how do
we get security um and that had
less to do with Marge  but he
actually also had a lot to do with
the purpose and um or with the it
was just an exciting question
I was in Afghanistan I
visited the troops there I really did we
set up cyber and at the same time
a few things
happened privately I was in  around the time our
third child was born Katja and
I got married and I also wanted to
rebalance my life I must say I didn’t want
these really bad hours anymore
or even then it was the time
when we had a lot of terrorist attacks
that means there was also a lot at the weekend there
was a lot of uncertainty and I did
n't want that anymore I wanted more
time with Katja I wanted time with the
children and from then on I decided that I would
above all act as a
great adviser, so to speak, through advisory boards and advisory mandates
which you also managed,
because at that time, from the
previous federal government, there was
a digital radio, created by Mrs. Merkel,
and you
managed it, um, I
think the legislature is four years, three
and a half, we started sometime in the
summer  and then it went until
autumn so roughly who else was there
yes we were 9 people um exciting
profiles super super diverse is one of the one of the most
diverse
teams I've ever had
so we have an age range I
know I'll have it at some point  once
aligned 25 years or so we
had almost equal numbers we have,
uh, people from different countries with
migration just everything in it and that’s why
I think it was so powerful because
we first thought through the issues as a team
and then
presented them to the federal government and  then we
have startup people we have people who
know big companies we
probably do hopefully hopefully
you know them all so ideally it was
in there
adapella has the power the Fernuni Hagen
was in there Christos of
course you also know on researchers exactly then
we have Peter paricek  he is one of
the experts on does not matter government from the
Fraunhofer institute then Viktoria
Schönberger was in there he can
probably also be one of the
data economists from whom I learned an incredible
amount about data fascinating
to listen to him the role of data and it
Gasser was in there something to eat Harvard is
now going to Munich  came
so yes what what is in the end so the song
would say so the project what is left of it
I think there are several so that
one is we helped to bring the
federal government’s data strategy
into being, so to speak, and that’s it
So of
course the ministries were published and everyone
worked out but we were a big
driving force behind it and what I like about
the data strategy is that it above all
pushes innovation forward,
we just had a discussion before we
did a lot of gdpa data protection but what is it  because with the
innovation side that often gets
neglected we become world champions in regulation
we should also
be world champions in innovation and they
attached great importance to the fact that data only
develop values ​​when I
use them and how can we
increase use so I found that to be a very
good approach  and in this respect i think
the data strategy is something important, but there
were also smaller things we
tried, for example, to train the
state secretary and
heads of department a bit in agile work
and to explain it to him
because what does it
actually mean when you
think and work together completely differently  It
also means feedback culture, which is also
very important for agility. We
focused on education and
tried, maybe it wasn't entirely
successful, but we tried to say
we had to completely rethink education,
so we always
said arithmetic and writing  Reading data
so that has to be yes, we have
already had a friend’s education topic, we have to
rethink education or other
other topics that we have tried to
connect with
me internationally too, so we have already done a lot
I would say you are already a
bit in  Hals said so data
is for the right topic but this
claim that can be heard everywhere for years
wait for the new oil
you think is wrong that is amazing because
actually some of them could always
agree that that's
the new saying  yes that's
nice the picture is just wrong so
if I use oil then it's gone then
I've used up that's not the case with data
but the opposite is
the case the more often I use data the
more comes out of it the better it gets
when  you look at Google, which is
fantastic, what I use in the search engine, so to speak,
is on the one hand
sought for the first use for the
search engine and optimization, but then
it also goes into, for example,
all the translation programs that
have and so on and so on that
means using them  Data two three four
five times, depending on that, then there is
vertical use, so if I have something
about health Google then it goes into
the vertical sector and that's why
I think the picture is wrong and vice versa, if
I store oil, for example, then then
or that's why it came to me  also the question
with gold then the value is due to the fact
that it is stored the data humbug
is the humbug you have to use it and that's
why I found the picture misleading
when we say it's
the new gold we also said a lot of
that  I believe that in many
companies and we are
no longer talking about personal data,
but also about
company data, i.e. environmental data that
we record, has led to
many companies, especially the
famous medium-sized companies in Germany,
simply becoming insecure,
moment if that’s how  Gold is then
blocked, but it's in the basement and then
I'll see what happens to it, maybe its
value will increase, maybe I can
sell it and as a result, I think we
actually did
n't promote innovations but actually prevented them
because the exciting thing is when you look at the
data  with a new
perspective, something new often arises
when you bring this example, that
the planes collect
an incredible amount of environmental data, i.e.
air temperature and yunamit, and
actually the data that Lufthansa
and others have collected have
helped me to make weather forecasts, I
think they  Forgot the number I think
it was more than 10% which has improved a
great deal and environmental forecasts
play a huge role in
agriculture, so how much fertilizer do
I need, what about the water
and so on and of course
people would probably be of the from
Lufthansa hasn't come now but
because they have this data protection
and say here you have a look
at it but if I say it's the new
gold then oh you won't get my gold
because that's how I give it to you it's gone
no it's not  the data does
n't get corrupted if I copy or
use it and that's why the picture is
difficult in my opinion if you
follow it a bit then you would
probably also believe
that you actually have a rather skeptical prognosis for the future of
Germany
and you say man here the
digital world that is somehow not
exactly helpful for a country like
Germany the others have
left us behind and are much stronger there but
still I know about you or there are
also conversations from you where you
are actually not so skeptical
As you might think, yes, a
good question that I
'm also being asked right now, maybe
a question is how I get up in the morning
today is a wonderful sunny day
here in Hamburg, so in that respect I look,
of course,
we have three, we have three children,
of course, I have to be kind of
optimistic  I think
as always it's not black and white we
have a lot of great things we
still have incredibly clever
innovative minds here in Germany
fantastic innovations
and great solutions are created here and here is energy
and we also have the
locational advantage that we
can fundamentally do diversity  we can do
federalism, we can do decentralization,
we can also do diversity, we have
learned that, of course, it can be done much
better, it must be done much better,
but we are already good at it and why
is it so important, because innovation
occurs then, as I just said,
when we  from different
perspectives various teams are looking at what is
developing better solutions and, above
all, innovative
is that you say that this
real production of things, i.e. these
physical things,
building systems is not
so easy to copy and
Germany is very good at it  yes that
's exactly the second one is, so to speak,
we are good at innovation the second
is we are we dominate the
physical world and it is not so
easy to master we
also see what problems Tesla has from time to time
or the others too  and
mechanical engineering is actually a
complicated matter and
we are probably still the leaders there, but
then, slowly but surely, we are making both the Chinese
and the Americans
compete, and I think the
decisive question for the future is
will the hardware of the
physical world succeed in the software  to
integrate and thus come to a better
solution or will the
software be people who are going to
dominate the world, i.e. the tesla idea who who
who actually wins this
game and my firm belief is
that we probably still
have an advantage because the others have this
physical
We don't have to master the world yet, but we have to
do it now, of course that was also what
Volkswagen now has to do to bring the
software and hardware worlds
together, and that's
also a matter of diversity, by the way, because
mechanical engineers tick totally differently than
a software development company,
so that's what one thinks  of course
in engineering, which means I have to
plan well in advance because I ca
n’t just throw away the physical world as easily
as I say, so to speak, so
now I’ll redesign my architecture
and my software, which means the
agility I have on the one hand
is only possible to a limited extent  transferrable
to the other side and now a small
example and bringing the worlds
together so that they
develop these solutions respectfully with each other and you can
take a mobility solution but that goes
further that goes beyond that goes beyond an
energetic solution we discussed a short time
beforehand no how do I get it
actually in the real estate sector new
energy energetic renovation that
will only work with an
artificial intelligence solution and so
you can actually do every area of ​​real
estate exactly and that's exactly what it's about.
We have a large real estate
portfolio in Germany and the question is
many of them are still energetic, so to speak
on a low standard how
do you actually get
the resources
that are financially available and
because we are rising interest rates that is
less of course how do you get
the co2 neutrality drive the
company has also committed how do you get
that done and that  will only talk about
innovative solutions so I don't know
if you've ever dealt with hydraulic
balancing that does
n't mean that it probably doesn't mean
why too, so the radiators that you
have distributed around the house are usually
not properly adjusted like every
pump is not right  adjusted, which
means they don't warm up evenly
and then you do a so-called
hydraulic adjustment, which means that
you try to ensure that they
are correctly controlled and warm up equally,
which means fewer losses
Temperatures and quickly check
and so on. Insanely
complicated process that calls for
artificial intelligence and that is
trying, for example, the LED
is currently trying
to develop a solution with its own innovative company, together
with a farmer who can do that, so
speak again  Hardware comes together
with software discuss automated
automated
hydraulic balancing
apropos AI and or
ai you know surprised when
chat GPT has really popped in the last few months
yes I thought it was great I have to
say so I
quickly logged in and  played along a bit
and yes we know
training data up to September of last
year and then we also know of
course American influenced that means
a lot of what I entered that didn’t
know anything because then it was
a bit sad but for
example I have to  I was asked about the
geopolitical conflict with China
and I found the answer
really well
differentiated, so it was to say yes,
we have a differentiated
relationship with China because on the one
hand the rival is on the other
hand, but we are also very closely linked with the
supply chains  connected that
means a silly thing is not
so easy possible not bad so
that was a differentiated answer I have to
say don't be afraid you financed
all the experts behind it
who say yes
seen as one of the really big threats now next to  the nuclear war and
and somehow in the virus say
the greatest danger to humanity
actually yes of course I have also
seen person of interest and all these films and of course I know this
scenario vice versa I have to say I
did my doctorate in programming neural networks
so that's what I mean
I have an artificial intelligence that's how
it's called today I
built a huge programmed simulator
and dealt with it in my doctorate and
saw the power of it
and you're probably asking the
wrong people
I sometimes say I love
technology I love everything and  uhm and
that's why I believe that there
are great great opportunities in it, of course,
atoms, energy always has a
down time and we have to get it under control
as humanity,
but first of all I believe
that innovations have a potential,
a positive one, so somehow always
said believe  I do
n't get that far that
it could really become a danger
so kind of
machine programming then
fight against human beings or
as if it's all so far in the
future despite the Chat GP advances
all that for years  or a decade
is not possible, of course we
also know that exponential
developments have a tendency at the
beginning, very slowly,
I don't see it and I
actually believe that these things
can still be controllable, but yes, in
every technology there is a
theoretical potential  when I
look at the development and GPT does
a lot of things really
exciting so when you see which
different learning algorithms have been
linked so to speak so that
this machine has become so good then
it is impressive but in the end
it produces a text and you  you
also know the examples of what was then
asked about Badoo as
French President and so on,
of course there is also a lot of
nonsense coming out of it, I believe that the
danger lies in that and that is the real
debate that leads us back to what
we are in  digitalrad tried
to initiate namely the question how can
we all actually educate ourselves how do
we actually deal with this
information can we then
actually was good news
i.e. distinguish right news from wrong
the whole topic deep fake
that makes me a lot more worried and so
that  it's more of a
democratic challenge if you
like, or a social one,
not so much that I think
the machines control it now and
I don't think so, but that's why
teaching our children not everything
that's on the internet is true, not
everything  jetp will say is correct
and but how do you find out and how do
you form your own
opinion how do you form your own
facts how do you actually do that
and I think that is the real
challenge a bit satisfied with
the type of regulation that is currently in place  so there is
also a look at the
big platforms, they've been around for
decades, the question is, or at
least ten years, the question is
it really
shouldn't be looking at it any longer,
maybe
the big platforms now have the keyword
cyber secret  contributed to a bit of enveloping
democracy in that
suddenly there were foreign actors
in election campaigns and stuff like that,
yes, I think we
probably have to get a little closer via the stack,
so I think what
actually happened with Twitter and come along with
many of them  It
's really, really difficult and also
a danger in networks, and we should
actually talk about it again, how
we deal with it, because they
aren't publishers and so on and so
on, you've already discussed all the problems
several times, so if we
are at the top of the stack, that
really worries me because the
differentiation is no longer there
and also, as I said, armor,
that would be a topic, we can
talk about it for hours and really
split up, but then nobody takes the time
anymore  that's why we did
n't have to tinker with the topic of
discourse, we can do more about our platform, we
can do more, so how can we
really have discourses again
that are differentiated, that are
respectful, that are also fun,
that today also feel like it, oh yes, it's
really complicated  But I want
to understand that the first consideration is to
make links and then fall into something, to
reject or
like or dislike us or
whatever, if we go deeper, that is,
go to the cloud stack, there is
actually more of a question I think
already that they have made many more secure
here I think it is actually
the question we make our
dependencies and how can we
prevent login effects that we currently have so how can we
actually because you ca
n't actually switch at the moment and also through
them  equestries, it's also very expensive to move
your data away again because
I think we have to
go from Amazon to Google under competition law, plus
the fact that they're
working their way up the stack and try not
just to offer the service cloud, so to speak, but
logically not, but
then the platform  the whole tool world
but then also the data above it and
i think we have to deal with it from a
sovereignty perspective and from
a
competition perspective
sometimes happens
i think we have to get better
and because then the original question was
how i see it  on the regulation i
think some things are good and right in the beginning
but and that's what i
said before we ca
n't just be world champions in regulation
and in europe in germany i often miss the
opposite side the
innovation side the experimental side
the side that is  Says yes, so we
regulate, but for example AI, we already
have an AI regulation
with the second one, but first of all, please let us
develop AI solutions that
can keep up, that are really so
innovative and the USA has us, but
the USA has us too  China because
image recognition has already
lagged behind and I think it would be
more important to look at where we can
develop intelligent solutions. Looking
at China, are you surprised that they are
not making as fast
progress on certain things as
you think, for example these
Chip development so again because
my line perspective on it seems to
be so difficult in certain
areas that obviously a
country like Taiwan
is almost more attractive to please and you because this
thrust technology comes in that
seems to be the point than building it yourself
it was easy
not possible and somehow
I would have thought that China would get
everything done, they are super smart
and build it, but apparently there are
certain technologies that even China
cannot build with all the resources
and where they are years ago
Surprising for you, yes,
especially in the chip area, it's
not surprising for me, because we're
back to the physical world, it
's just incredibly complicated when
we go to the small structures,
well, everything that's ten
nanometers down, I don't know  or now at the very
cutting edge 5 or even smaller that
's just incredibly complicated and
the second thing is that the USA has always
said more or less clearly and openly that
they have the strategic goal of
China adding one or two chip generations
behind and him and  China also
very systematically and this has just
happened again
with new
acts that they
just don't get supplier products, so to speak, which
means they are regulated and even
partly extrateritual, which means that
they also say ASML Netherlands
so you're not allowed  more if you
want to do things with us you are no
longer allowed to deliver to China and that
keeps China at the back the question is
and that is a strategic question
the
US China conflict has become very intense in the last 12 24 months  much more
intense and the question is will this
lead to the Chinese now
saying oh we need to double down and then
really trying
this race again in a completely different way and
then throwing something at it, so
even more than before or so  will it
lead to them catching up and
what does that mean
or will they always be one or
two generations behind so in that respect it
doesn't surprise me that they
haven't caught up yet, but I'm
unsure what will
happen next strategically if they
take Taiwan  what would probably be possible without any problems
with the
military force, then there is
the central factory or the total
company
that can do it worldwide and
this year were well, I do
n't think it's that easy, Taiwan is
also an island  with native
structures, plus that the USA
has also made far-reaching commitments and also delivered weapons, plus
that Taiwan itself is now
a well-fortified military shipyard,
by the way, also a well-fortified democracy,
democracy ranking is now a
very eight or so and now not quite
sure very high low the country so
I think it's not that easy just
that the chinese army after everything
the experts say and here it can
only quote that they say
they are not yet ready for a
large scale invasion that could be small so
to speak  strikes but make a
large scale invasion there will say
the experts they are still around 24 months
away but and do you have a
perfectly valid question what is the
long term or medium term
scenario Dennis
the party and especially first
people have always said that in
his in his lifetime  Term of office
but I believe it will come
to pass in the meantime
he will achieve reunification of metal
goods and the Chinese people
are very nationalistic and very
patriotic, which means they want that
too and vice versa Taiwan has
drifted further and further
away and is becoming more and more western
than  a democracy and is expanding its own
structures with the support of
the USA but also many other countries
because it has an incredibly
important geostrategic location next to TSMC that is like
this picture that is like the
aircraft carrier that is
floating and
in that respect there is
forces really drifting apart China with
a clear declaration of intent and
vice versa Taiwan also with a small
projection how the game will end that
it is unclear especially if we
look beyond 24/25 I don't know
and there is the scenario that
at some point there will be a conflict  and
maybe also to a thoroughly
armed conflict that is in any
case not unrealistic and
not improbable and that is
of course something that
then that is then already threatening
with I don't even now play
any wars or anything like that
well so if we close  a
confrontation between, so to an
open war, so there are many
escalation levels, so don't get me wrong,
so it's also possible that then,
so to speak, only attempts are made
and then there is deterrence again and
then divided, you do
n't even know how  it may also continue
that China has no idea how the
curve will continue, that if
economic growth continues to decline,
that the priorities are back in the country,
so there are many, many,
unknown, it can go in many, many ways,
also with the USA, by the way, but in
the scenario, which is at least not
unrealistic, is that there would be an
open armed
conflict, of course, that would be
a big world war between China and
the USA, that,
as I said, is a lot of unknowns if you
were at McKinse for a few years and
were also a partner  you're actually
already taken care of economically insofar
as you say okay the rest
I'm doing this now out of ideology or do I
just feel like or do I want to
get involved in society keyword
now under your time
public jobs and now that's
earning money in your  Life is over either way
I would like to
get involved and she would also like to
be paid well for good work
but something like that, so to speak,
to take on an operational job again, so not
before why didn't
I already say I have only now, on the
one hand, I have an
incredibly exciting one  Portfolio which gives me
more of the privilege of getting to know different
industries and different companies
and working on topics
that I love, I love technology and
item and I love them, he's fine and
when they come together, these are
exciting tasks where we
shape the future, they just make me happy
what I really
enjoy and I enjoy I enjoy that
I have time with Katja I enjoy that
I have time with the children
that's not a bad thing if you do
n't have to work 60 80 hours, so to speak,
that I believe if you now have
more of  listen, where can you find not
actually so you just
heard from so you actually do that too, from
my point of view it's a pity not so
much of what you're
saying here on Twitter you don't do that on twitter you're
not that vocal now either  so do
n't want any social media persona of you
there's something now there are
n't the LinkedIn posts now or you do
n't express yourself so publicly no
why not do it
is understandable so they say i
have an opinion i want to take part in the discourse
how why aren't you in
LinkedIn still as, so to speak, just
with a woman you can there is
a vacuum right away so many
people I think others can do it
better they might have more
fun with it so I love the discourse I
also love the conversation no and I
think we can  also
continue to talk about many, many topics and
we have already done that elsewhere
but I don’t have to have it publicly
why so that’s not already more
people yes but reach personally that
’s not my goal okay but especially if
you  Opinion or
information too difficult is
actually with more people that's
better yes I think if so of
course I understand what you're getting at and
have
from you that was Twitter again so um
no we've talked about that several times
I can't  we are
also trying to think about it, we can do more
and the course can do more, how
can we actually shape discourse differently and in a
new way and we are chewing on that,
we are very busy and
we have already
found fellow campaigners and I think we
will at some point  we might
succeed in finding a format
where we can discourse in the form
we would like it to be
differentiated and respectful and
really dedicate ourselves to it intensively when we have
found that then I think
I can also imagine scaling at the
moment it's not mine
But focus, you also make investments as a focus, in addition to
mandates, so a
little that you know you are
involved here or something, yes, and then
give a few examples, yes, hey jobs,
for example, already Berlin startups
exactly
and the two and that just a
great business model because because of real
problem for real people so the
core idea is easy to say we
have LinkedIn example so for white
color workers so for the brain workers there
's a lot of platforms there will be a
concern age the companies invest
that was, so to speak, the all the
Whole recruits with machines were geared towards
this type of people in Warfare Talent,
but and we are finding out
more and more here in Hamburg
that there are no more restaurants open on Mondays
color workers or, as hey Jobs
calls them, the essential workers are becoming more and
more common this year Nursing staff are
becoming increasingly rare and are now
also being given the importance in recruiting
that they actually deserve,
namely to say hey, we’ll take care of
you and we’ll help  that you
find the right job for you where
you might also earn 100 € more
or where you get one was different
appreciation or no longer
have to drive so long and for which hey
Jobs is developing a platform and a suitable
offer that I think is fantastic and
in the early
phase you then somehow put 50, 80, 100,000 euros into it,
whatever,
but it means you do it
more often than you already do, I'm
very, very, very selective, okay,
because I think that makes sense  if
I also get involved if I have
discussions I
talked to Marius again this morning about what else
can be done what is on the market what
is the development how do you do
it in the company and I think then
it makes sense and  Of course, I ca
n't scale that at will, so
I do it very, very selectively,
but I find it really exciting and I think it
gives me the opportunity, for example,
to be in a young, dynamic, growing startup environment in Berlin and that
's balancing on something again
I see in the USA or what I
do somewhere else I find what he
is somehow interesting with you, you are one of the very few
people who have switched from
business to politics or a
public sphere, so to speak,
at a top level Jörg drives
Cookies one of Gomez I think
got a great name in
business and then
many others in yes we
actually had sebastian and I a few years ago
founded a network
querwechsler network um all
querwechsler and um
from economy to politics yes exactly and
there  there are very, very few, in fact,
we also published a study together with the Hertha
School,
and Germany is
actually the country
with the lowest cross-change rates in a European comparison, i.e.
the lowest rate, we believe that
it’s not a good idea, erm, to be precise
not a good idea in either direction, so
business and and and administration
are so closely related more and more and
through
regulation and so on I think it's
bad for both sides if there
is no exchange if the
business world says the politicians are
just crap anyway  Ne is so gladly
taken and politics say yes these
business people with whom I have nothing to
do it's only about the money and
to stay with the picture and they have
no purpicson no honors
whatsoever so in any case there is
a lot of scolding about each other  I do
n't think that makes sense because we have to
shape this life together in this society and on the other hand
it will of course also help the administration in particular
if people have an
understanding of technology with IT or
how to do modern communication,
in the image from earlier  to
stay or with project management
experience that's something that's simply missing in the
public sector, which is still heavily
characterized by lawyers and lawyers,
I'm not sure if payment
is the only thing we've
seen in the Ministry of Defense, so
we were able to do it in a targeted manner, for example
that we said come here
to Cyber ​​Unity you can
do things you ca
n't do anything else or that we said well
here you can do something for
your country I believe that we are one and
I know so many people
around me  they would say of course I'll do
it for three, four maybe even five
years, but the structures
don't allow it and I think that
the administration also misses out on such
potential, such brain potential
plus that I think, as I said, it would be
enriching for both sides
I think it's a shame I thought that was wrong the
problem is when only a few
people switch
over, of course they repel the system very quickly and that's
why I think there should be a
broader we also have a broader
will to achieve that you have
that means you  you obviously worked for the old
federal government
in the ministries and and you
would, but even if
somehow Mr. Haber came or Mr.
Scholz knew that would definitely have to be the case, it’s
about the content of the task
and a lot I wasn’t a
politician either, I was a civil servant and  I was
basically talking about that you could
say there were two secretaries of state and
you can say I was basically the CEO in the
Ministry of Defence, that means
I did the planning I did cyber I
did breasts I did the
digitization I made the
procurement processes I made that is
a management  Task and I have
also said quite often I get that the
the task that sets the
parliament that is the highest
democratic institution the Bundeswehr
is a parliamentary army that means my
task description comes from the
parliament my supervisory board was the
committee the defense committee I have to
implement it  what comes from there
or an advice and to
say sorry to the politicians you
said we should do the following x tasks in
the Bundeswehr
but we need y-money you have to decide
if you don't give us the money then
the tasks have to be reduced but
I can no longer fulfill the equation,
that's how I have my job,
but I have to decide whether politics will
say you get more money and
another area less, or whether they say
yes, then we'll cut off the tasks,
politics has to decide that's
not my job  of course Ms.
Lamprecht so our former
distribution minister a bit sorry in the
end
you mean because she had to give up the job in the end
I think it always
hurts when you were
noticed definitely not
nice for her but I don't know her
can't say anything about that well  well
i know you have to go
on again right away no you somehow got
called to me probably still
pick up children or something like that
but come
ok ok what what what is the economy to create so
what activities are
pursued so where so work on it yes that
is that is that  on portfolio life you
can't give an answer,
I'm working on different things that
means portfolio life
you can probably say more clearly
what your goal is today or
soon it will also be around he
everything again so you then have something in an
operative  you can say that is clear
for me i just have to talk about different
things in different roles
if they do it at some point recently from time to time
you will be consulted in advance
or or
a lot of fun super super professional
super exciting and also included in the CDs
being tactful is of course the
tact then, yes, you know how it works very quickly,
but that is extremely interesting because
you can then discover something new
and try to
make cross-relationships and contribute my knowledge
plays a role, so I think it's former
herrings, that's different,
well, yes, they have a very interesting
question, e.g. at the moment and there is
a question, how can we
actually create the stakeholder universe
by being in the
shareholder universe
and we all learn from it  yes, so
you have employees, you have potential
customers, you have the regulator, you
somehow have experts and how can we
actually manage this complicated structure
with the same analytical and
strategic riga as we
do in the share or universe and
select the question they have
for me, so to speak  have asked
can you help us develop a solution
and the solutions we are
working on that is called reputation IQ which
means it tries to measure reputation as
a probable proxy if i
have the best proxy we have across
stakeholder groups and stakeholder rankings
Although in a very consistent, clear and
digitally first way, of course,
clearly digitally firmly about the mobile and
then saying ah if you have understood that
in different
dimensions of reputation across your
stakeholder groups then
you can of course start to
analyze levers how can I improve
what is missing  here e.g. you think that we
are not sustainable enough
maybe I have to
invest in product development or you
think we are not responsible
enough oh I have to see what I
can do there,
my communication is an
area where I actually thought I
could  also that sounds
very good right now, until then it was
n’t really described that well, so you
explained that, so
reputation management means I
always thought you look at how you are
seen in certain areas as a
brand or as a person or something like that,
that’s also correct  I think
we have to look at the reputation in the various
stakeholder groups because it is
of course very different, so if
you are a company x you will
of course be perceived very differently
in your community, but
maybe talented or
potential talents will look at you completely differently
and say yes
you don't have such a good reputation with us, or
vice versa, you have a
very good reputation with potential talents, but as soon as
people become your employees, the
reputation goes down. This is measured using the
same methodology, namely
directly, not via, not via the proxy,
not via the  medienspiegel but
directly with the stake or groups via
polling, i.e. via surveys in order to then
develop a score from it and
then you can use comparisons and
analyzes you can still additional
data with individual is a
data infrastructure underneath you can say
oh well the potential talents think
I’m great but  actually my
employer is no longer so I'll get
my service and find out
oh they all say what do I know as soon as I
start working here bad
management culture know but externally
my reputation is great because the product
is fantastic because I know something
what and then you can try to
analyze that and then you can
go into management and much more
purposefully and also steak
stakeholder groups more specifically than if
you go so broadly about communication
okay okay okay now I
understand
and yes, already rich portfolio
Activities so
where a bit of suspicion would be two
things so the wish that you
are a bit more visible that's
why I think it's really cool and that's
the second to
judge that but I always think if
you have a [ __ ] impact of course again
if you  in one thing but the
portfolio there you can give a lot of connections
I was wrong I don’t know so
obviously you see differently and
enjoy yes when different is a question
of what you want to do
so I’m glad you
wanted to come here and
you could sprinkle that and maybe
something else just somehow a few months
ago that was very nice everything
clear